let's talk some ball let's talk some
draft with our friend albert breer
who pens the mmqb every single monday
and must read material for sports
illustrated back here on the rich eisen
show how are you albert breer
i'm doing great how are you doing rachel
i'm great let's start first up
before we get to justin fields um about
trevor lawrence and the sports
illustrated feature on him
great stuff great writing great material
mike did an awesome job on that
absolutely no question i could not help
though
but think like what if josh rosen said
what trevor lawrence said or his father
or his coach and what if somebody from
justin fields camp or justin field said
something like you know
uh that it's unhealthy to have a chip on
your shoulder or justin fields high
school coach said you know what
he walked away from it right now he
doesn't need football like i it really
struck me
you know as yeah in that regard albert
may be um
and i'm not normally a glass half empty
type guy
yeah and it's a fair question um you
know and i i would say
um you know like if i if i was another
player like i
i'd probably be wondering that if i'm
another quarterback in the draft
i'd probably be wondering that um but i
also think it's indicative of how
unique trevor's experience has been um
here's what i mean by that can you think
of another player
who's as smoothly gone from star high
school player
to number one recruit in the country to
star college player
champion at both levels state champion
in high school national champion in
college
the number one overall pick well i don't
if you remove the words
if you remove the word smooth from it
i'd say jameis winston
who hardly lost what was he but was he
number one the number one high school
cup like
back in the country i don't think so no
i mean even like andrew luck and we
think of andrew luck in that category
right
but i mean if you look it up i mean he
was still like 70th or 80th in the
country like which is outstanding
you know as far as kids put but i mean
it's not number one
but the only thing i compared to is
maybe peyton manning
right like like that he was a like that
sort of recruit coming out of high
school
and um you know his number one overall
pick in the nfl draft
i guess that would be the one person you
could compare it to um and i'm not
i have no idea on john elway i don't
think recruiting recruiting rankings
existed
right back then my point is though rich
like
like it's just who he is you know what i
mean like i mean like he's had
a fairly smooth ride and it's not to say
that i've been bumps along the way
but i mean this is a kid who's always
been able to sort of create his own
motivation
and his own motivation has been to be
the best and it's and it's worked out
for him at every turn
and he's won championships at every
level and he's been the best player at
every level
and so you know i just think it's maybe
a product of how unique this kid's
experience has been
um even to a guy like andrew lucker or
jameis winston the two examples we came
up with there
like even with those guys like those
guys could probably still look up
you know in their high school class and
say they'd like they have their own
brady six
right like sure there's six guys in my
high school class that were ranked ahead
of me
like he never had that right so i just
think that it's sort of
a product of what trevor lawrence's
experience has been
which very few people can relate to um
because his experience has been you know
it's like again like just such a unique
experience that was my first initial
reaction to this piece and these quotes
yesterday
what i just sort of set our question in
this conversation up with
was an overnight sort of like huh like
what if somebody else had said this sort
of thing
and you know uh and how that would be
viewed as a red flag or
not into football or not completely
ready to compete and things of that
nature um but my first initial reaction
was well
i mean kids hardly ever lost so why do
you have a shoulder chip if somebody's
ever
not ever looked at the scoreboard and
said i'm better than you right
very often and now that i'm talking to
you
also in particular it's interesting he's
got a coach
his new his next head coach is going to
be somebody who's not used to losing
either
and i i'm wondering if you know the two
of them
you know like how's that gonna work when
both of them
urban meyer and trevor lawrence combined
have such i don't think they lost more
than you know together
i don't think their losses even reach
double digits maybe
combined it's maybe scratching it what's
gonna happen by like you know
week eight in jacksonville no i know
and like and in an environment like like
let's be real here rich like seven and
nine would be
a win right like seven times like like
going seven to nine that's a six game
improvement you might be the most
improved team in the league
and have a losing record right so like
that's the thing about it is and that
look like that was the main question
with urban right like was that every
loss you know is it florida and ohio
state the way every loss crushed him and
affected him
um you know that was a big question with
urban like when it comes to the pros
and you know 12 and 4 11 and 5 is an
outstanding year
how are you going to handle the weeks
where things didn't go your way right
um you know and i think urban's aware
too that like it's just
it's a different deal you know like in
in college i mean one loss can literally
you know i mean if you're in a place
like florida or ohio state and literally
you can feel like your season's over
after a single loss
so um you know i i think it's going to
be interesting to see how they handle it
and i think it's a fair question to ask
like a kid who hasn't had a ton of
adversity and
a and like that's through no fault of
his own either i don't want to make this
sound like it's like a
course a shot at him but he really
hasn't had a ton of adversity
and then he got a coach who hasn't lost
a lot but didn't handle losing great
when he did lose um
it's just it's going to be fascinating
to see because again and i can't
emphasize this enough
like seven and nine i think in most
people's worlds for the jaguars this
year would be a roaring success yeah
it's plus six
that's plus six nine column i mean and
so
you know obviously your ears burn um you
talk to
so many people in the league what what
is the general sense before we move on
to the draft
of what scouts coaches front office
executives think of
of how urban meyer is going to fare
in the nfl what's the general sense i i
i think the general sense is like a lot
of it's going to depend
on the infrastructure around him and um
you know i think that's from these guys
own experience
you know what i mean like it's it's a
big job being a head coach in the nfl
it's especially a big job when you've
got some say so over personnel
which urban's going to have in
jacksonville and so
like i i think a lot of it you know is
is going to
boil down to how he delegates and um and
the people that he's hired
you know and so it's going to be guys
like joe cullen on defense and brian
schattenheimer daryl bevel on offense um
his general manager trent balckey um you
know because i i think there is a
feeling that like just from a culture
standpoint
and a program building standpoint urban
has that like that that that won't be an
issue
the issue could be if you know you're
going to be hard charging the way you
are
you were in college and you're not
giving players results that's where it
can be problematic
and so to get those results in the nfl
general you have to have really good
infrastructure around you
and um and you know so i think a lot of
it like a lot of nfl people look at it
say
if urban staff's right around him like
he could be a really good nfl coach
uh but a lot of it's gonna boil down to
how good a job he did
and let's be like i don't you know i
don't want to sit here and i start
assigning blame before anything's
happened on anybody else or
you know if urban doesn't make it
because that's on him like his
responsibility to have hired
the right coaches around him but there
is that feeling that
you know urban's program um which has
been successful everywhere he's been
i'm in his way can be successful in the
nfl
but it's still only going to go as far
as the results
take him because getting buy-in from nfl
players is all based on results wins
and giving guys an ability to get rich
and
getting those results is gonna ride you
know not just on urban but a lot of
people around yeah some of the nfl
people i spoke to certainly
um uh took note of urban's
uh statement on free agency where he
wasn't
able to uh vet interview so
significantly somebody's ability to work
in his
or the team's culture he's about to
create
that you know there's no home visits you
know what i mean like
that's that's as close to recruiting
obviously you can get in the nfl is free
agency
and uh his comments about that he's
always sold
rich if you think about it right like
what he's always been able to sell
you can't sell it the same way in the
nfl and that's that's part of the
learning curve for him right
albert breer here on the rich eisen show
from sports illustrated in the mmqb
what is going on with justin fields uh
where where did the second pro day come
from
why did it was it born out i ask you a
bunch of questions and you can go for it
yeah was it born out of dan orolovsky's
comments specifically
somebody with the espn platform talking
about his work ethic
the 49ers trading up to number three
they'll show
at ohio state and for justin fields
they'll show
the niners exactly what he can do in
their system
walk me through everything going on with
justin fields
i know it was born on i mean it was born
on the niners trade
um that's what i think it was born on i
like my feeling is that this happened
um and this came together and it's not
just for justin but it's for trey lance
too
on monday um that you know part of the
reason the niners made the move that
they made
and i think they're being earnest and
you know i'd heard this before they came
out and said it
um they're being earnest when they say
the decision hasn't been finalized yet
um they wanted a chance to see these
guys live they wanted a chance to zoom
with these guys they wanted a chance to
dig around these guys
without having to sneak around to do it
you know what i mean like if you had
waited until like three days before the
draft to pull off this trade
you're probably trying to hide all of
your intentions and they didn't want to
do it that way
and so a big part of that is going and
seeing these guys throw live
and um you know i think the chance to
get
the chance to see each of these guys
throw live was important to the niners
so they have a third pick it's a great
situation for whatever quarterback is
plugged in there
so you know it would behoove the
quarterbacks to
to give those give the niners a chance
to see them i think what's really
interesting about i can give you this
little nugget
so the guy holding the the guy holding
the the script
at ohio state um the last pro day was
was john beck who i know you're familiar
with who's been the throwing coach for
zach wilson and for justin fields
process works with tom house down in
orange county
the guy holding the script this time
around was corey dennis who's the
ohio state uh quarterbacks coach and
like my understanding is that script was
put together with a lot of influence
from nfl coaches and having talked to
nfl coaches and a lot of influence from
kyle shanahan in particular
and there was there were west coast
and quick game elements baked into the
script
that to those who were there looked a
whole lot like what the niners do
so i i think you know for the niners
this wasn't a private workout
but i mean to some degree those aren't
allowed this year
but to some degree it had the effect of
a private workout because they were
getting to see a lot of the things
that they would want to see if they had
a quarterback in that setting
did they take requests like you know uh
like a jukebox yeah like or like a dj
you got any requests got anything on the
route tree you want to see
like i'm not sure if they took i'm not
sure if they took requests but i do
think one thing that was
that that's sort of interesting that
justin did do um
so you know i think there are some ncaa
rules about like
who can go run routes for him so um
so last week or uh two weeks ago
whenever the first pro day was
they had um they had chris olavey and uh
and garrett wilson
running the routes for for justin and i
for one reason another by rule those
guys couldn't do it again
it's ncaa draft rules whatever it is so
they had to
do it with new new guys this time around
so
justin was throwing to two freshmen this
time it's jackson smith
the jigba and uh and julian fleming for
the two kids
and my understanding is like justin was
like as the workout was going on
coaching these guys up on routes and how
to run this route and how to run that
route
and that was interesting to me too just
because
if you look at kyle shanahan's
background it's
in receivers he was a receiver at texas
right
and so i think getting to see justin's
intricate
knowledge of the way that um
that though that the receiver should run
around the way he wanted them to run
routes
um you know where justin's head is with
all these questions that have come up on
him
i think it's just sort of an interesting
detail and maybe something that kyle
shanahan and john lynch can take away
from the experience well also too albert
breer is the if there are questions
about
um justin field's accountability
um as well as you know for himself as
well as
towards the team seeing something like
that has got to be a plus
yeah what is the real what let's drill
down deep like what is the
true evaluation of justin fields on this
front since that has been
quite a bit based on uh a couple of
comments from the espn family of
of evaluators and information folk
what is the deal with justin um yeah so
i mean like first of all i
like i really like daniellovsky uh i
think you know he's a great dude
he does a great job you know so um yeah
i i
i think assigning blame here is is tough
um
and i like and i i think you know kind
of
what dan was getting at um those
questions did exist
um i'd say at least a month or two ago
um and and i got them
you know and probably got them in the
same manner that maybe dan dan got him
um i don't think work ethics ever been a
question with justin
what i where i do think the question is
is going into him making the transition
from being a collegian to being a pro
is how he's going to allocate his hours
and
justin if you look at him you can see he
works in the weight room right like
that's never been a problem
um in the field work like i've heard
from guys in that program that
uh you know you could come in at 7 00 am
and
there's justin throwing to a lava in
wilson you know getting extra work in
like so i i think the thing with
justin's going to be
like how does he allocate his hours as a
pro and reallocating some of those hours
into the classroom to get better in that
area
because honestly if you look at the
flaws and like the couple bumps that he
had at ohio state
um and i think sometimes we overplay
those a little bit but
a lot of them related to him playing
hero ball a little bit too much
because he's always been so physically
dominant that
he could like he would always kind of
lean back on his physical ability
and be able to pull his team out um out
of tough spots that way
and so i think for justin it's gonna be
how do i allocate my hours as a pro
and i think he played in a you know i
mean i know he played the pro style
offense at ohio state it's just going to
be about making progress in that area
and maybe putting more hours in the
classroom and not that you have to take
away from anything else because you're
going to have more
time as a pro than you had as a college
player but just being smart about the
way that you do that
and do you really think i mean i know
that they
i've asked everybody this i'll ask you
this too and pardon me if i've already
asked you i asked it of sean mcvay
last hour um by saying i know it's not
your house it's as a matter of fact
somebody else's house but you know he
he knows shanahan personally and he he
competes with him and he also knows what
it's like to evaluate at the quarterback
position and be aggressive
to get the one that you want so he i
thought he was a perfect guy to ask
really they don't know who it is like
they actually struck this deal
by saying we're fine with all three as a
matter of fact let's keep grinding tape
and it's better to be in the position if
we have a choice of all three i mean
like for real
they don't know who it is
honestly honestly i think that at least
i think at least a week or two ago there
was a point where if you ask different
people in that building you might get a
different answer on who the guy
should be but they might not know they
might not know in terms of being in that
building
yeah and i i think kyle and i think kyle
the the fact is
like kyle's the one who's gonna be
pulling the trigger on this right
so really kyle i think like this would
be my guess
i don't want to like play this off as
like being inside information but
i i you know i mean i've covered the
league for 15 years i know how a lot of
these teams operate and everything else
and i
you know i i think that like for kyle
it's gonna be a matter of
i have what i thought at first and i'm
gonna go through the process
and i think his dad could be involved in
this too um
and at the end we're gonna figure out
who the best quarterback is and i'm
going to take all the input distill it
and figure out what i want to do i also
believe this like in and i've been told
this
a few times by a few different people
they believe that there are five
first-round
quarterbacks in this year's class so for
better or worse the three quarterbacks
are going to be in there
like they went into that trade thinking
each of those guys was a first round
quarterback so
and it's interesting too because you
bring up sean and
in a certain way isn't it almost like
sean just traded
mac jones for justin fields or trey
lance
what do you what what do you mean by
that you're well the guy with the
the guy with the guy who's like the kind
of smart game manager type for the
physically gifted like like part of
part of moving like if you look at like
sean right and sean and kyle are
different
yes and obviously sean and kyle are very
close but in a certain way
like sean got fed up with the mac jones
so he went and got himself
a trail answer justin fields don't you
think that's fair well he definitely
soured on the guy who was there he
wouldn't use the phrase of souring he
that mentioned production he also
was typical of mcvay albert he took
responsibility of something that he did
wrong
that that that that led to the
relationship with he and goff no longer
being tenable when somebody of
stafford's capabilities and abilities
and still
major upside becomes available that's
the way that he
portrayed the end of that relationship
but he also did say that
he he believes that the niners have
absolutely identified one in particular
while grinding tape just to be sure like
he believes that yeah and i
and again like i think that that's fair
and i think that it's
like look like i said like you hire kyle
because
in large part he's great on offense and
great with quarterbacks right
that's why you hire him and you trust
that guy to make that decision
like that's that's that and so there's
one guy making this i think there's one
guy who's going to have the trigger at
the end and it's kyle
and it should be that way that's nothing
against anybody else in the building
um i just think it's you know like i
said like i i think
you know what you're talking about what
like and what sean said there's probably
right is that sean
said that kyle's got it in his head like
it had it in his head when he made the
trade of who the guy is gonna be
and now you know he got like he and the
rest of the
team are working through the process
to either confirm that or decide
player a or player b rather than player
c is
what's best for us long term okay i know
i could tell you being father of the
year while also providing this great
information
so i do have one last thing to ask you
if you're okay with that is
because albert breer we we keep
mentioning
kyle as in shanahan the other kyle
involved in this draft at the top is
pitts and what is the scoop with what
you're hearing
with him because in my mind that is the
guy
who might make the falcons say yeah
we're not going to choose one of these
first round quarterbacks now we're going
to we're going to
stick kyle pitts with julio jones and
calvin ridley for
matt ryan's final window of significant
opportunity here
or trade out because somebody else has
fallen so head over heels for kyle pitts
at four what do you think is going on
with him
in the draft here um here's what i would
say i
you know i think kyle like the way
people talk about kyle pitts the way nfl
teams talk about kyle pitts
is a lot like i remember teams talking
about quentin nelson
on three years ago now that sounds weird
because the guard versus the tight end
but like there's universal agreement on
who this guy
is which is exactly what it was like
with clinton nelson
and then the question became and nelson
like
okay he's a guard do we take a guard
that high
and you know i i don't think that the
colts
would ever regret what they did and i
think that there are probably a couple
teams that picked ahead of the colts
in 2018 that wish they were thinking
like the colts
so i think that's sort of where pitts is
where he's seen as
maybe the best prospect at his position
in 15 years
since we're going all the way back to
vernon davis and then the question
becomes how much you value the tight end
how much you might be getting out of the
tight end
within what your offense is um and
everybody's got to answer that and for
the falcons it's going to be about
timelines right
like if you draft pits or trade down
well then what are you doing you're
shortening your timeline because you're
going forward with matt ryan
and throwing pits into an offense with
julio and with ridley
and i mean they've got some good top end
talent there they need to
fill out the bottom of the roster and
they need they've got depth issues but
they've got
they've got some players there um you
know i
like if you wind up taking piss you're
shortening your
your timeline if you want to take a
quarterback you're extending your
timeline
and i will give you this nugget to leave
you with on that yes sir
um terry fontenot the new general
manager
i can tell you he has gone out of his
way to build a relationship with matt
ryan
he showed up at a couple events um where
matt ryan was at
um and on top of that they've
restructured matt ryan
which makes it difficult not just to
separate from now it would make it
difficult for them to separate from him
a year from now and so a lot of their
actions
just they aren't the actions of a team
that's separating that that that's
really looking to divorce
it's quarterback in the last 13 years
now
maybe a quarterback they love false them
at four and they say we have to do this
but there are i mean there's just
there's been a lot of signs
that relationship building with matt
ryan's been important for terry fontenot
and arthur smith
and that tells me that they're at least
considering
the idea of going forward matt ryan in
the short term and trying to win now
and worrying about getting your
quarterback in the future maybe two or
three years down the line
albert you're the man enjoy the rest of
your day and your weekend let's chat
before the draft thanks for the call
that's albert albert breer on twitter i
follow him you should as well he just
said something that echoed the comments
of somebody earlier this week
involving the nfl draft we're hearing a
theme
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here